[موسيقى]
حاول شوي من الزاويه المسائيه نخفض ما
فينا لحتى نقدر نامن الكهرباء شريحه اكبر
من واضحه قد ما بيكون في عندي الاستهلاك
اقل اتمنى انه كميه كهرباء محدوده يعني
انا المحطات التقليديه لما يعتمد عليها
بانتاج الكهرباء معروف في استطاعته ومعروف
الزرويد تبعه طيب انا قد ما بيكون في
الامساك اقل فانا فيني اغطي شريحه اكبر
اذا بدي يكون عندي الاستهلاك اكبر فرع
يصير الشريحه يعني من غزه اقل من مقابل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا بلاش احس انه عم بوصل على شغلي الشمس
طالعه او لسه اول اول شروق الشمس حسيت انه
بكير شوي كانه لسه بيكون فيه مثلا هلا في
وقت البرد بيكون في برد قارئ صباحا فهي
ممكن تكون مشكله على طلاب على موظفين
بيروحوا على شغلهم بكير بس انا مرتاح
اتخيل انه الساعه توفير للطاقه ويعني
العالم تعودت على نمط معين همم فاستغير
بالنسبه لنا صار يعني بكركب وخصوصي
للاطفال وخصوصي للموظفين